يواصل مساعده السابق ، نيسان جريج كيلي
، المحاكمة التي استمرت
لأشهر بزعم مساعدته في إخفاء
تعويضه
الآن في مقابلة حصرية ، أخبرني جولد
أنه لا يعتقد أن
غاري كيلي سيحصل على العدالة
إذا كان لديه محاكمة عادلة في الواقع يجب عليه
لقد
خرجوا بالفعل في
الواقع ، فأنا أعرف كيف يعملون ، فأنت تعلم
أن الأمر يستغرق الكثير من الوقت
لماذا لأنه يدافع عن أنه غير مذنب ،
أعني أنه إذا كان يقر بالذنب ،
فإن المحاكمة كانت ستنفذ بالفعل
الأحكام الصادرة بالفعل
ولكن هذا جزء مما هو عليه
سميت من قبل الأمة المتحدة
بنظام عدالة الرهائن ، أعني أنك
تحافظ على الشخص بشكل خاص عندما
تجرؤ على
القول إنها بريئة لفترة طويلة جدًا
كما تعلم ، ومن ثم لديك دائمًا
إمكانية في النهاية
أن تُدان ضد كل
الأدلة التي لا تفعلها  ننسى
أنه في اليابان فاز المدعي العام
بالقضية في 99.4
من الحالات
99.4 وأنت تعرف كيف يبررونها
يقولون إننا نقوم بعملنا بشكل جيد مما يعني
أن الدفاع  غير
موجود لقد كتبت كتابًا هناك فيلم
وثائقي وفيلم
وعنك وعن حياتك إذا
نظرنا إلى الكتاب ما هو الغرض منه ،
لقد تم أه مسجونة
فجأة في نوفمبر 2018 بين
نوفمبر 2018 حتى
ذلك الوقت  بأنني خرجت من اليابان في
ديسمبر 2019
، لم أتمكن من فتح فمي عندما
قررت عقد مؤتمر صحفي
، اعتقلوني مرة أخرى قبل المؤتمر الصحفي ،
لذا خلال 13 شهرًا
كان لديك صوت واحد قادم
من جزء المدعي العام نيسان  من
الحكومة اليابانية
التي نقلها بعض المتواطئين الفرنسيين
، هذه هي القصة الوحيدة التي سمعتها ، لذا
كان من المهم للغاية بالنسبة لي
أن أروي جانبي القصة التي
تم تأجيلها لفترة طويلة ،
كما تعلمون ، لقد عوملت بهذه الطريقة
لذلك من الواضح أنك تقول يا نيسان قالت
ذلك وقلت ذلك لذلك قال إنها قالت لا
تنتظر لحظة فالأمة المتحدة لديها
مجلس خبراء في
الولايات المتحدة وقالت
إن اعتقالي كان تعسفيًا
وأن عملي الإنساني  لقد تم انتهاك ghts ،
فقد طلبوا من اليابان إجراء
تحقيق حول
كيفية حدوث شيء كهذا في
اليابان وطلبوا
منهم تعويضي ولكن من الواضح أن
السلطة اليابانية
لم تجب على ذلك وقالت إنها ليست
ملزمة بذلك.